ah good morning John here so what's
going on right now which is that a
Halloween with all the nerdfighter
pumpkins never asked for it always get
it always love it so cool Lizzie just
bought Star Wars now honestly I'm
excited about it
III know that they could do bad but with
Marvel they've done very good Helaman
really mind a little bit right now
so Lucasfilm as an effect studio called
Industrial Light and Magic which is like
the best name for effects studio ever
and back in the early 80s they hired a
guy named John Lasseter and he and a
bunch of other people created a computer
graphics department at Industrial Light
and Magic Island then sold that
department off to Steve Jobs for five
million dollars and it became pixel then
in 2006 Pixar was purchased by Disney
for seven point four billion dollars so
a company that was basically an
afterthought for Lucasfilm became worth
more than Lucasfilm to Disney which then
bought Lucasfilm in its entirety
including Industrial Light and Magic for
four billion dollars amazing there is no
moral to this story I just thought that
was interesting other things going on
yesterday was Darcy Day the big reveal
of William Darcy I'm playing Assassin's
Creed 3 which I'm super excited about
gay video game season there are still
people who cannot watch my videos
because hurricane sandy knocked out
their power into those people I say I'm
sorry I hope your lies get back to
normal soon I have roba doesn't be cold
finally the biggest piece of news out
there that America is about to pick its
president for the next four years I know
not all of you are American I'm sorry
that's what I'm gonna be talking about
for the rest of the video but for those
people who are not able to participate
in the stuff that I'm about to talk
about I've created another video just
for you just for people who don't live
in America and if you live in America
and you click and you want that video
then you are bad person but for
Americans and also anyone who cares
about the American presidential election
which should be everyone Harry Potter
Alliance and the vlogbrothers are
teaming up to create dftba a somewhat
awkward initialism standing for don't
forget to vote America the dftba
initiative has two parts first part
there
as a graphic and it is linked in the
description and you should spread it far
and wide to encourage all of the people
who can to vote do your civic
responsibility your duty posted
everywhere leading up to the election
and especially posted on Tuesday to
remind people to go and vote also there
are really important things that you can
do with the Equality FTW campaign this
year the second person of the dftba
campaign is about more than just
spreading the word online it's about
actually going to your polling place and
pose doing the nerdfighter sign and we
will send you a free dftba sticker
that's right absolutely free you're
under 18 you can do it too and we'll
give you just for being excited about
elections even though you're not like
legally you can't vote we'll still send
you a sticker because I feel bad for you
all I have to do is go to dftba.com and
post a picture of you at your polling
place or with your ballot and for people
who've already voted you can just go to
your polling place and take the picture
and submit it and we will send you a
sticker and that is all except that it
is not all because another link in the
description is a playlist that I've
created today because there is so much
stuff to talk about that I've created a
playlist that you could sit and watch
and it'll probably take like a half an
hour we'll watch all the way through it
so if you want to watch that playlist
there's like a bunch of videos including
one with me and Catherine talking about
Darcy Day the reveal of William Darcy on
Lizzie Bennet diaries is playlist thing
is a thing that I've never done before
it doesn't work on mobile just on your
computer so hopefully you enjoy it
hopefully it works and John I will see
you on Tuesday oh my god it's gotta be
Tuesday ah